but what i thought was awesome about
this first 22 minutes is what it
achieves undoubtedly is emotional
investment and for you to root for this
guy
it's not so much about the plot of the
game
this is setting up the character journey
of this main of the protagonist while
they do do that with the spider-man ps4
i think this one actually achieved it
better
the game comes out tomorrow so we're
going to watch the first
22 minutes of spider-man miles morales i
know this footage was released a while
ago but saved for last i suppose and i
want to thank everyone who commented on
the last mos morales reaction video we
did because of your comments i have
decided to go forward
and i pre-ordered spider-man mozzarellas
for the ps4
because i wasn't aware that it can come
with a free upgrade
once i get the ps5 so thank you guys i'm
getting the game this week let's watch
this damn thing
so courteous minds
[Music]
[Music]
oh god he's a hero even when he's not
spiderman
save the couch
[Music]
that is so cool
i got you hey thanks
no problem hey uh you think you're gonna
add that new spider-man too
kid yeah maybe original's just
my guy you know yeah i know
hey is tails bodega around here yeah
bright yellow sign down the block
chemist
thanks beautiful work by the way
maybe leave a little room for the new
guy just in case
and i'm not him that's just the same i'm
just a really big booster
like what daily bugle the convoy
if you wanna be spiderman you gotta
learn how to deal with this man
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
damn mr convoy not yet you're still
securing a couple inmates
but it feels good seeing the guys who
escaped last year going back to the wrap
real good the raft's an eyesore but it's
secure
as long as the octopus-related flaws
have been fixed
let's hope okay closing in on you
we'll be there soon yeah doc offers me
don't let mom know i'll be late
smile and then the shopping
hey mom yeah but uh the bodega was out
of coconut milk
gonna check a store downtown oh thank
you
but avoid midtown that prison convoy is
making traffic a
nightmare oh yeah
avoiding that man how does pete do this
secret identity thing
completely stresses me out he doesn't
stress him out at all miles it's easy
for him
walk in the park all the time
okay be cool be cool helping spider-man
protect a giant prison convoy
you can handle this you're not just
helping spiders breathe out you're
being spiders
[Music]
i love how he's like struggling to
breathe it's so great
pete you here just down in some rocket
fuel
kiss me just
drinking very very carefully there it is
okay go time he looks too on route heavy
it's gotta be hundreds of felons escaped
from the raft last year
now it's time to move them back in
police aren't taking any chances
especially not with our guest of honor
getting a lot of interference here one
of those guys who helped
doctors in there think so could be
vulture
it could be scorpion could be
someone bigger we got a problem
hold back miles let me take it i got
this pete don't worry
don't try to prove yourself too soon
buddy
it's secure
[Music]
oh
[Music]
those cops are dead
payload compromised response team
dispatched
sit tight helix too peter i'm sorry man
i didn't mean to it's okay
we got this just need to contain it
before
before that happens
hello tiny spiders
you think they'd take them out of the
suit to transform
no
i've got rhino but you have to contain
the escapees learn your controls
learn the controls miles tutorials learn
the combat moves
you're insulting him in the background
oh
come on miles oh
can't let pete down i need to get this
under control
[Music]
kind of terrifying
never see the big guy up close like this
freaking nuts
he's a work of heart all right not the
phrase i used
wow
[Music]
[Music]
overzealous this year alexis
oh
that's great i love to jump into the
building something demolished i love
that
it's like a movie
this is starting to feel real bad man
don't think like that we're going to
stop him as long as we work together
right people are giving me a hand up
here
hurry once yeah i got you
okay yeah i got this take it away
the cutscene take it away
[Music]
[Music]
the collapsing of the depth of field
baby
[Music]
you know you're ruining christmas right
the last six christmases i was locked
behind thirty feet of steelhead
i intend
he's a low energy menace too easy
maybe he's a weak minded
yes
hey mom yeah coconut milk
still trying to find it it's been kind
of uh an adventure
yeah uh sorry trying to catch the grain
grab the milk and hurry home some
important milk
now we're never mild
[Music]
yeah yeah what do we do let us raise
temperature
[Applause]
no bueno no bueno miles
are you okay
[Music]
oh my god
no no no oh no i've got him head in your
way
all right okay yeah
wait a minute
don't bring rpgs to the prison convoy
next time
maybe don't bring rpgs anywhere
thank you
very much get out of here spider-man
you're making things worse yeah you're
making things
worse
can't you see we're trying to get away
with crying
[Music]
oh man there's so much chaos
so much for one young man
he can't move he never loses
[Music]
hang on man hang
spiderman you good
[Music]
wake up wake up wake up man
wake up man
get him miles this spiderman is broke
i would like to exchange for new
[Music]
get out of here
[Music]
[Applause]
did you discover that for the first time
i think yeah yeah yeah
oh man miles get all this revenge after
all the crap rather put up through the
first one i love it
i love it
you survive while your mentor perishes
there's your motivation
man you really feel that venom punch you
really feel
i am excited to see you try
small ones
you're on his back
you destroyed half the city
finish him
what's the worst
[Music]
[Music]
what's going on with me man
i wonder if he even knows about his
camouflage yet
man there's they just like thrust you
into this huh yeah
damn what guys
wow just wow
simon krieger head of r d at roxanne
energy trustworthy pleasure to meet you
trust her you too
uh sorry i think our ball landed in your
yard
no actually did us a favor we uh just
bought the place uh we're planning to
tear down for a build but uh looks like
you beat us to it
i wanted to thank you both of you
taking down rhino solo
you are going places bud thanks
but he's still dangerous ah we'll
hold him for the police you know i
always think these super troopers are
overkill until
something like this happens nope judy
calls
hey uh really great to meet you both
future's looking bright hello
hey he's right yeah let's clear out
let the police do their job
yeah yeah okay
gotham city
bioelectricity wow gotta be honest
little jealous hey look
i got nothing on the og did we try and
test tomorrow
a little voltage analysis
man yeah sorry i've been meaning to tell
you
i'm not gonna be around for the next few
weeks
is this some kind of p joke i don't get
no
uh mj's headed overseas for the bugle
and requested me as her photographer
kind of a working vacation for us i
don't feel like that voice matches
not exactly look i don't know if i'm
ready to fly solo
i screwed up today big time with the
helicopter but then you delivered big
time
you saved my bacon miles i got lucky
hey i did this gig for eight years
without backup
and you better believe i screwed up lots
of times
but that is how you learn
what's this suit but first
you gotta take the oath oh yeah um
okay i promise
to do everything in my power to protect
this city
i promise that's it
that oath a real thing totally
definitely didn't just make it up i've
had many spiderman
yeah you would not be the only one
new york's only spider-man see you in 20
to 40 hours of gameplay spider-man
i'm new york's only spider-man
pool homelander you're on the rooftop
of the city
who's new york spider-man who's new york
spider-man
hoo-hoo-hoo
this is an example of a game that you
could just watch somebody play watch it
screw it it's like so much fun
awesome that was really awesome man i
can't wait to play
so uh for this first 22 minutes it feels
complementary to the first 22 minutes of
spider-man ps4 where in that you have
peter parker
waking up day in the life of peter gets
the call
and he has to go take down wilson fist
while going through this building
learning the maneuvers and such and then
they take down the big baddie there and
here while there's some complimentary
things that happen
that serves more as a prologue i think
which leads into the actual
story of the game yeah this essentially
is like a prologue of sorts but it
actually feels like
an act one if anything yeah you know
what i mean like the
spider-man ps4 felt like prologue and
then you get into act one and then this
feels like
just pure act one i loved it the setup
of miles morales being
someone who is trying to make a name for
himself is just looked at as like
spider-man junior or the kid to
spider-man
in some way he doesn't have to get
anywhere near the amount of respect and
you feel that right away we talk about
the mural on the wall and are you going
to put spider
the kid on there and they're like
hesitant to do it
and so you feel this anxiousness to
prove himself and like the inner
dialogue or
actually the external dialogue that he's
having throughout peter wouldn't do this
peter wouldn't do that he's constantly
looking up and looking forward and
not really recognizing what he what he's
capable of doing you feel this sort of
insecurity in his voice that he has this
opportunity
to be something amazing
yet he you could tell that there's this
lack of confidence that he has which
only makes sense
with that with trying to achieve the
confidence he's
making some you know careless choices
and getting ahead of himself here and
there i really loved how when you know
rhino breaks out the prisoners break out
and you got people insulting him
miles while he's trying to fight and do
damage control
so it's so wonderful so wonderful yeah
well i thought they really
this is a weird note to hone in on but
really the use of
the voice cast across the board helped
this to become that much more immersive
for me because yeah i love that you've
got miles worrying out loud about his
own
repercussions you know the things that
he's messed up in this operation and
those little moments where it's clear he
wants to prove himself so
he takes the lead on like trying to
secure the containment pot or whatever
and that goes awry and then later on
you've got peter in the background and
you can hear him just sort of just
saying peter's stuff to rhino basically
and yeah like it just made everything
feel like that much more of an engaged
storyline and two i mean they they
introduce miles in the first game right
correct am i correct no they don't they
don't no
yeah yeah they do excellent well
then starting it off here knowing that
and having it now verified for me
uh it felt like a really natural place
to start this out and i love like it
seems like spider-verse has really blown
the doors off of everything in terms of
like i love that we have peter being the
mentor to miles and then you know
leaving for a
couple weeks and and putting new york in
his hands really like the vibe back and
forth between them and that was
something that like isn't mind-blowing
now but for a game like this really
pulled me in and really uh kind of
enhanced that character tension of just
like yeah
he's not supposed to be here doing this
convoy thing he's supposed to get the
milk back home to his mom but also he's
gonna go help out peter and stuff like
that and uh well
i don't i think he doesn't realize how
similar of an experience and a journey
he's having and that's kind of what the
ending note is of their
relationship like when he's trying to
balance his personal life in the very
beginning of this
and he's saying i don't know it stresses
me out how do you balance both i don't
know how peter does it we know as the
audience said no that's not easy for
peter that's that's one of the things
about peter parker
yeah how does he balance both and then
even having that ending touch with their
dialogue exchange of like trust me miles
i've made
many mistakes i have caused addiction i
commit i keep making mistakes so don't
worry so
like miles keeps telling himself short
in that way and i love in terms of a
narrative of the first 22 minutes
how there is like a little short film
happening here in and of itself even
though it is just an act one setup rhino
going off and then while you hear like
the funny stuff happening with peter
trying to fight alexi in uh in the
background of
all this miles is stuck with just the
prisoners you know people who are not as
they're dangerous but nowhere near a
threat level that rhino is
so peter's handling rhino and miles is
handling the prisoners but then who's
the one
that ends up taking down rhino it's
miles and peter isn't even around to
witness it
he's not he's unconscious at the time as
miles like unlocks
his new potential and everything yeah he
unlocks his venom punch
or the the venom powers within him just
in a visual narrative structure point
he is just as worthy or capable of
holding up the spider-man mantle
even though he has a hard time believing
it the visual language of him taking
down rhino serves that
and what i thought was great too coming
off of the fact that
you do play as miles periodically in
really short moments in the first
spider-man game
obviously he doesn't have spider-man
powers in it but one of the
most intense levels i thought was when
you're actually playing as miles
no powers and you just have to sneak
around rhino
and it's very scary to have that be his
big level
in the first spider-man game where it's
a sneaking around trying to get to
a certain destination around this rhino
character who's stalking him
and then to have this end on he goes
toe-to-toe with him
with the spider-man powers and defeats
him i think there's something very
cathartic and showing yeah an evolution
within the character there too
yeah man now all you got to do is beat
rhino five more times and they'll put
your face in here
well they're dealing with the
repercussions of what happened uh you
know after the end of spider-man ps4
with doc
ock and all the other villains factored
into there but you know even a little
bit more complementary things some
some stuff that seems to mirror it in
some way and i think a lot of us already
picked up of it
from the like even from the first
trailer some of these guards and stuff
kind of remind you of like the disabled
team from the first one i think there's
just so much more craziness to come but
what i thought was
awesome about this first 22 minutes
is what it achieves undoubtedly
is emotional investment and for you to
root
for this guy it's not so much about the
plot of the game
this is setting up the character journey
of this main
of the protagonist while they do do that
with the spider-man ps4
i think this one actually achieved it
better just because of
you know the the sequel and then it's
miles you got you have to
and everyone knows peter parker there's
a whole wide variety of reasons
of why it's more important to do that
this time around when your follow-up
game
is not playing as peter parker yeah
you're playing as miles and lastly i'll
say
um that face is not warm enough to be
that
that peter parker model is not warm like
it does it doesn't match for me it
looked weird
whereas miles look great still but peter
looked weird
well and in a continuity where i feel
like a lot of people have already gotten
used to the older model to then have a
sequel in which you have this new model
that looks younger than the older mother
it's a little confusing yes but he's not
being killed off
i mean i was afraid he could have a lot
of us were thinking maybe they will go
that path but no he's taking a vacation
that's right man he's just piecing out
for a couple weeks take a vacation
learn on your own for a while protect
the city peace
and uh some craziness will ensue during
that time he's leaving town during an
election
not the time for peter to be leaving
i'll say
especially not now going overseas no
less and also i think the music is
phenomenal here a really great
soundtrack and i think the sound design
you feel it you feel that sound design
improvement
especially with the venom punches you
you have to really feel like
there's something different about it and
more than just the look and the powers
and how you see how
the the effect it takes on rhino you can
just hear it
like it's it sounds so crunching
you know yeah yeah they have a really
good like surround
mix too just like everything sounds
really crisp and then like the natural
sounds mix really well with the you know
more space
yeah suit sounds and stuff you know all
right guys well first 22 minutes of
spider-man
miles morales achieved hopefully i can
get around to beating the story sooner
than later guys what do you think
majority pre-ordered the game leave your
thoughts down below subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell hit that like button last but not
least
all right john you had one in mind for
andrew hayes oh
that's right andrew hayes if anybody
in the real rejects universes is primed
to set out on a life of crime
mech suited up ready for destruction it
is
you my friend the next apocalypse it's
not gonna be a snowpocalypse it's not
gonna be a summer apocalypse
it's gonna be an andrew hayes apocalypse
because you know what
you're kind of a short guy and i was
like rhino's kind of a short guy too
you'd be the perfect person to shout out
i haven't seen your face i missed your
delivery it's the first time i've
attempted it in a while
and uh i hope we can talk again soon
shout out
a plus gameplay complete
rhino's a short guy isn't alexi kind of
short doesn't they make fun of him for
that in like other
iterations of the spider-man property
well he's in a mech suit the the thing i
i was like
the first well maybe i'm just going off
paul giamatti because he's tiny
inside fake